what's up reject nation thank you so
much for clicking on this video and
thanking everyone who's been on this
journey with us as we've been watching
scope game because we have made it to
the final episode of season one now
before we go into that i do got to say a
few things one yes this shirt has holes
in it kind of odd that you'd be wearing
a lego movie shirt on the last episode
well because the final episode i just
wanted to be as extra comfortable as
possible two we've been watching this
with english
subtitles and apparently we've had the
wrong selection this entire time so
those captions rather than the regular
subjects
regular english one so thank you to omni
media for pointing that out for us three
finally could start watching some videos
from our friend paul over at heavy
spoilers who's been killing him it's
good game stuff and i've been like i'm
gonna get you to watch your videos man
four we plan on watching this before we
even started squid game but we wanted to
cover train to busan capitalize on
korean cinema
hit that like button
and uh yep subscribe click that
notification bell full length watch as
long as you're sitting with a time code
over at our patreon reaction highlights
watch alongs included for many shows at
the same tier you get the option for
both lastly prepper thank you guys right
now these highlights for all the
episodes of squid game you guys rock
appreciate you guys bear with me on all
my overbearing notes so let's get to it
now people
[Music]
[Music]
that's right he rose to offense that's
right man gonna play american football
now
it was the most physical and violent so
any kind of violence is allowed sure
there are no restrictions
oh good double knot those things
[Laughter]
oh oh that's cool
that real rain or okay
for a second i thought they had like
some rain
get him
get him
god knee him in the balls
oh
oh yes yes
yes get him get him
see those actors threw down
choke him out put his [ __ ] hands
batman
[Music]
no
where's the knife no oh you got me
[ __ ] me
yes dirty
yes
oh my god he's like a big chunk out yeah
[Music]
oh my god
adrenaline boy
[Music]
i didn't do it
no man be mindful he's gonna come at you
with that knife
[Music]
oh god damn it no but don't let him up
until he agrees
i don't trust this guy man
oh i don't dress this guy at home trust
him either say come on man come on kick
the knife away go
be out there
wow
[Music]
yeah what would he have to return back
to yeah i mean he would be imprisoned
to be a
[Laughter]
designed to make you think and
everyone's gonna have a different
response
some people are gonna say this game
isn't worth winning wow it has his mask
off on tim
oh okay
well
foreign
[Music]
i wish they gave him the giant pig yeah
just like strapped
away
drop them off
[Music]
man i do not want to see sandwich mom
i don't know
huh
[Laughter]
better be a good christian
wow
did it for all that money but doesn't
feel victorious in the end not the least
a lifetime of trauma
oh [ __ ]
exactly what i didn't want
oh
my god
oh man you'll have to give her closures
some way yeah
some
[Music]
some grand lie
i swear to christ she's [ __ ] dead
[Laughter]
that was like it's
one of his motivators
didn't even get to be there for her
final moments
he's hosting a game show
it's fair and equal guys
come and win gee hoon's money
wow money really does not buy happiness
if they do some crap where he like bet
it all lost at everything
what's himself
oh
[Music]
seven four
what why what
no
no
we didn't see him get killed on screen
this is the one person
[Music]
[Music]
i knew there was something more to him
this whole time i kept saying it
it kept saying
he's surprised it doesn't look as old
yeah
yeah you know that fresh shave punch
[Music]
they're going to mug
[Music]
i'd rather have that problem yeah that's
a better problem to have
suffering
from
jigsaw
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's their job
oh hey he did get help
[Music]
i died anyway
[Music]
whoa
what a shot
yeah
[Music]
we should be dicks and make that
thumbnail yes
it's too good a shot now
wow he faded away like a ghost yeah this
got weird
sugar
that's why the host wasn't in attendance
[Laughter]
oh i think i'd always come and i saw
when i first heard about this [ __ ] yeah
i thought if it's going to wrap
oh that was happening on the image i had
no idea oh
oh damn is my man getting the makeover
oh damn he is yeah okay i had no idea
that was his entire time
it was like what squid game
[Music]
um
so
this is just for money
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
oh no it's slapping again slap game yeah
it must be
i need to stop the [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
such a nice guy i know
just wanna have some fun with his
friends
foreign
always watch it
[Laughter]
[Music]
i really feel like a completely
different person yeah
old man season two season two
bravo
that was a hell of a show wow man
that was the first time they [ __ ]
said the tracker director's thing i
think so yeah hey i did them all so just
do it right there wow
season two here we come here we come
hopefully enough people watch this show
to get a season yeah
those ratings gotta pick up if they want
that
games are going to get saw level craze
25 episodes
double the games
oh boy all right let's check to think if
my mind had registered that was gihon
from that whole
i saw that image that was that was the
first image i ever saw in squid game was
that dude with the hair wow with him in
the hair and my mind never through the
correlation that that was him
until i was like he's in the zone like
oh what that was
lucky duck
that would have ruined the whole thing i
wouldn't tell me right away like oh he's
gonna win because he's got to get that
hair down he's got it he's not part of
the game holy crap that that's pretty
and i know the show's done once no what
are we gonna do with ourselves now oh
wow it's been a while since i've seen
something that both that gripping but
also that just masterfully assembled
from front to back like and i hadn't
seen that i didn't see the old man
thinking i mean i always thought there
was something else going on
and uh i thought i found it
that we never learned
what uh like we didn't see him get shot
on camera yeah he's like the only person
they don't relish that with yeah or like
see his dead body being carried or
anything yeah or put into the cremate
crematorium yeah yeah so i thought for
sure i mean this is not gonna be the
last time we're talking about square
game guys
easter eggs and clue videos to check out
all heavy spoilers videos
perfect that's
all week next week which is a bunch of
heavy spoilers videos
all you cover is heavy spoilers and
squid game now and my responsibility
yeah i know
there's so much doing back here do you
really want us to go back to spiderman
because those are coming
don't worry
don't worry you'll be you'll be moaning
about those soon
yeah that was um
that was a that was a crazy finale that
was nuts um because
i mean there were a lot of it's i think
you know what's funny is like what what
really could have spoiled this show for
me is the fact of like when i would see
uploads going around about this show
before we watched it were all the old
man and that amber should keep him with
the title here and unfortunately i did
not i always saw an image like a couple
times so i didn't register with him and
the old man just seeing enough of him
should have been the indicator that
there was something yeah i've done so
i've been really doing my diligence to
avoid being spoiled on this show and
that was one thing that crossed my mind
when i saw heavy spoilers videos like oh
the old man's on the thumbnail
interesting i mean he is a fan favorite
character
that must have been leading to the clue
that he he dies
his death must have greater context than
i realized
because he was even messaging me about
like he was even messaging me about hey
i have a thumbnail idea but i would i
don't know it might spoil the show fruit
i'm like dude i'm gonna one more episode
left so i want to get it or not i want
to give my two cents but please just i i
can't i can't i have to avoid it for now
um
okay yeah i thought like the the
progression of guillaume was especially
satisfying
it's like from the first episode you you
see the
is it's interesting how they parallel
the first episode to the last especially
like the first
30 minutes
or not the first 30 minutes i don't know
like the first half of when he's just
being reacquainted to his life yeah back
to normal like he goes back to the atm
enters in the pin sees his mom
walks down the alleyway of the market
and you're seeing like just how
different like it would be
really fascinating to watch like the
first episode and then the last episode
and to just see the progression of this
guy who's like in the same
he's got he's he's got all his money now
but he's more
empty than ever before yeah where the
search for fulfillment came in
lack of money so wanting to you know
fill up his bank account and then
the journey to there
ends up leaving me and feeling hollow
yeah
on that thing of like you know these
these you know obscenely rich string
pullers of the world gave this to me so
now it's almost like yeah i don't even
want to touch it for fear of becoming
anything like them and also for them
like really resting on top of all the
terrible things i had to do to
be in this position and i i thought this
episode was interesting because you know
it starts out with
the showdown that we've all been waiting
for and it's a really intense part of
the episode and i think it's again a
real big credit to how they pace and how
they put you in the perspective of the
characters that so much of this is post
game so much of this is being with him
in the very sort of yeah hollow first
year after the experience and then you
know seeing a bit more transformation
you know after that but it's it is like
a very breathy very error-filled episode
like so many
of those scenes i really admired the way
they let his like shock play out
initially like that scene with his mom
is so heartbreaking partly because it's
like the same like one or two lines of
dialogue over and over but the feeling
yeah and it's like that was like one of
the main reasons he went and did the
game and i thought that too like added
to the drama because i was like is he
even gonna is he even gonna help her
brother out or is he just gonna set up
his money forever and like live in a
stupor well that man was heartbreak was
so heartbreaking about the mom too is
like because of this pursuit of money
he didn't get to be there with his mom
during her final moments which even
outside of an extreme context is just
another position that financial systems
put you in you know or can put you in
yeah
[ __ ] what she i mean what was anything
about him seeing his daughter and
everything you know and i i i do kind of
wish we got to see that i would like to
yeah i mean that was the kind of
it's an odd beat and i'm curious to see
how it'll matriculate over the next
coming days of you know just thinking
about it but yeah it's like we end the
show on he's going to see her
and he's turning right back around to go
back to the game and you're like no like
like the chorus core core motivator is
your daughter well what's cool about the
cliffhanger
he is like the katniss everett yeah
i'm gonna take down the hunger games
jeffrey writes in season two woody
yeah that's uh i think what's cool about
the cliffhanger is the cliffhanger is
the the last stamp on his character art
him declaring i'm not gonna like
literally standing up to them
him
saying um i want to know and and and him
deliberately disobeying you deliberately
disobedient
name that movie uh
deliberately disobeying
uh their final order yeah just to be a
horse and follow along and be an animal
get on the plane go it's no i won't go
live on your horse farm be retired
no he's just he's so haunted by it and i
i love that approach to it of how
there is
no
uh wonder or much optimism to come from
it's like they don't lean into the
silver
lining they don't lean into it all like
he he's alive
but he's broken
um yes he gets to see the brother of uh
of cyber but
i don't know i'm sorry
see the brother but you know she's still
dead
and it's it was an interesting
it was an interesting thing they did
they drew with it was pretty creative
because it's not exactly a one-to-one
like supplement
you know
it's not
john travolta returning home with the
son of
caster trust
face-off
but he brings us up when he brings up
it's like she loses a son and he doesn't
have um essentially his mother the boy
because the sister was like a mother so
they both lost
you know those roles in their life yeah
and now it's being supplemented here
with a
lot of money yeah
but load of money but you know it's
still like the closure of not knowing
what happened to the sister and not
knowing what happened to the son
is the biggest weight that they will
carry yeah unless he you know as like he
can't just tell them yeah like you can't
tell them who believe it might sound
crazy
together in fact he needs to prove that
this game exists yeah because there are
a lot of loose threads here there are a
lot of dangling threads yeah because you
had the cop investigating
i take it nothing happened with all the
footage he was trying to send
the
the brother uh front man being haunted
by these so you see that he was
disturbed
by those moments you could see perhaps a
kid and the fact that they cast him for
it
leads me to think they have bigger
things in mind for that specific
character
and perhaps a chance for
i don't know about character change but
conflict within i've heard it said
because all these things about the show
being so popular i've seen a couple of
quotes flying around from the creator
writer directors basically saying
there's not a season two locked yet i
don't exactly
have a plan but if i did i might want to
explore the front man so i think that at
least goes to support that as yeah
because he is like a pretty notable
actor even in the states you know yeah
yeah and um
so you have that
because yeah i mean having the cop
investigating all those things and then
knowing the history with that brother i
think that's the brother becoming the
front man after winning this i call them
the squid games but after winning that
you know yeah
it is fascinating how
it's called squid game the show starts
off
with a prologue explaining what squid
game is
the final game is squid game as expected
and i love that the final game is not
and i wonder if it's a disappointment
for i i actually am very curious for
people if
that ult because all the other games are
so theatrical yeah so extravagant damn
expensive and you know and uh and this
one's just in the dirt it's just in the
dirt and grimy yeah
and scuzzy and disgusting it was like it
it's just a brutal fight that felt very
real i love that too like it really felt
like two people who don't really know
how to fight
and
yeah yeah and who are at different odds
on like how cunning how like brutal they
want to be but they're desperate
yeah
and i thought uh the choice you man i
was about to have my heart rate down
where i'd be like with all that [ __ ] if
he's gonna get the money insane saying
we would have murdered her yeah and i
get this is to show us that you're
better than him but damn dude
just at least turn him over so he drowns
saying lou gets one moment of redemption
yeah i was surprised by that i guess i i
was like [ __ ] that dude's gonna grab
that knife and stab you yeah
the second he went for the knife i was
like you will stab you you left the
knife right next to me gonna stab you
and uh he did it because yeah i mean
what if they returned empty-handed
what does he have to uh no it wouldn't
be right right what does he have to live
for i mean like he he already returned
because there's there's nothing
for him waiting for him at home yeah
it's like you wouldn't
you would return with all the benefits
of the trauma and literally everything
that drove you back into the game to
begin with yeah it's like and i think
that is a crucial element of the show is
is doing that second episode where it
shows yeah pretty much every a lot of
people didn't want to do this and so
many of them had pretty much felt like
they had to come back
and uh yeah like to sell that to pay
that off at the very end like it is a
fascinating thing because yeah there it
seems like no matter who you are unless
maybe you're the gangster there would
just be no life after this for you
really yeah it's it's fascinating how it
just paints everything in a different
light like a re-watch would just be so
interesting specifically for what's his
name is
let's call him old man
number one
it is interesting of how you have the
old man here and every single thing they
did where he just seems like giddy just
seemed like senile old man or because of
his brain tumor he's not comprehending
the severity of the danger
you know like he's just playing the game
and so it's funny it's charming it's
endearing when he's like playing red
light green light
and he's got that big smile when he's
playing the marbles game dude yeah like
just having fun like willing to die hey
this was just like my old and it makes
sense why it would resemble his home out
of anybody else yes nobody else was like
wait a minute i know this you know yeah
and um
and then it comes back you're like oh
you're bastard you dick oh bastard well
you're more twisted than anybody because
yeah it's that like i just needed to to
feel the rush one more time
i was bored so i needed and not that i'm
not under the impression that like they
were probably obviously given
instructions of like if you can avoid
killing him
overtly in front of people do that you
know because he's the boss
and uh yeah so even still though what if
he died during the [ __ ] the tug of
war
one game where i was like you would have
done you would have he would have
absolutely died yeah yeah 100 and so i i
it makes me curious and it also makes me
curious to re-watch and see if you know
maybe there are a lot of moments with
him that are kind of authentically his
advanced state and dementia and whatever
else you know like maybe that is real
because it seems like you know he's like
i wasn't lying about this tumor i wasn't
lying about a lot of stuff so
maybe he is a bit of i mean he's got to
be a bit of a kook
and he almost died during the prison uh
not the prison riot the scene that's the
cena resembles prison yeah yeah
absolutely yeah so he was terrified and
pissed his pants and stuff
gihon really looked after and it's
interesting because other than the tug
of war game
gihon doesn't really have
um like an immediate death on his hands
now because the only one was ill nam
uh like the fact that he like was
cheating during the marvels game i know
i'm almost done i'll feed you soon
um yeah the one that was the immediate
death
like the one that would be strictly on
his hands yeah would be him
uh
like the tug of war one uh
group thing you know
yeah you know it's easier to be like we
always kind of saved each other at the
expense of not saving the other team
but it wasn't an intimate experience at
all
uh yeah the most impersonal game
yeah that was uh
this is a six a distant game that
twit that's only entertaining and
amusing for the people who uh
it's nihilus jigsaw yes
literally it's not about appreciating
your life it's just like life is so
boring and harsh let's just let's do
some games
let's do some games guys how bad do you
want it you want some money let's do it
it's interesting i only gave just enough
for you to get
how why this game was created
like you don't get all
you don't get like a giant exposition
dump because it was getting frustrating
because i was like
watch
how far does this go beyond the old man
and uh yeah but you don't really get
much but obviously dealing with the
these elite wealthy mother efforts who
can't uh just
can't get up anymore so they've resorted
a lot of the exposition throughout this
episode i do admire that those
characters are like
okay so how does squid game work oh i
see this is an old game you guys used to
play back then and what's the rules he's
got he's got a handicap for this guy
that's why he's on one foot i see thank
you for the info you're welcome
what's gonna do you're gonna return to
the squid games
just returned
well that's the thing is i'm like wha
what yeah what happens because it
doesn't seem like he can return in a way
where he has control or where he can
sneak in like uh the the i'm forgetting
his name now but the detective did so
i'm like he would have to re-enter as a
player yeah i'm like well sure you can
re-enter having that on your shoulders
of like i braved it once you know i'm
the hardest core person here but at the
same time he could easily
he's got to face six more trials with a
bunch of more random stuff so it seems
like a hard way to prove your point i
feel like with the right government
people
the right people who you can trust who
are not involved in this game you can be
like look how much money i like how much
did he have
he was finally learning five
billion it was like 49 it was like 49
billion right something like that yeah
how much money
does
han
win
american dollars
how much is 45 so that is the top
newsweek
uh
exchange rates for the win god dammit
just tell me how much this is
okay
i don't want to sign up for your
newsletter how much is okay uh
38 million
uh so okay so it transfers
the total prize money is roughly 38
million 393 239 okay and each
contestant's rough value is 84
195.70 okay so with that in mind
it's like you can go and be like look
there's clearly no record of how i
possibly got all this money i didn't win
a lottery like how do they cover that up
that i feel like that should be
explained
the season two is all the accounting
the bank's just like you've deposited in
a while you deposited 30 millions of
dollars like that you were broken in the
negatives all the time and now you have
38 million us dollars right so
like there's gotta be how else would i
have got this money well let me tell you
like
it's this crazy thing that i went
through why do you think these people
went missing go to the police station
like there's a version here i could see
where you can lend some weight dip hey
come on like
isn't this suspicious that i have this
much money well yeah i think you could
also theoretically he links up with the
detective at one point so if he could
find you know his superior the precinct
whoever he's trying to send the
information to he could corroborate that
you know and there could be some kind of
growth of that investigation
theoretically but then uh they have way
more money than he does to bury this and
kill all those people they need
shadowy organizations of like
governments are in debt and they borrow
money for these guys though nothing no
rules apply you're dealing with people
who would like we're converting 45
billion and that and so like for the
people who are in charge of this game
we'd be converting like a hundred
trillion yeah yeah
per person silly money silly silly
amounts of money uh but yeah anyway this
is an awesome show uh not one not one
episode here lacked every episode i
thought was great every single episode
just what it needed to be um really felt
like a really long movie fantastic
fantastic stuff guys leave your thoughts
down for screw game below what do you
want for squad game season two thank you
so much for being here last but not
least let's send this with a
you knew this was coming jt you're the
only
asian brother
at our shout out reward here for patreon
so you know what that means oh here we
go
if anyone on our patreon page
would be asked to compete
in the squid games
it'd be you
just by default yes they don't care that
i think you're part japanese
part japanese american japanese living
all the way to hawaii
i would probably get more money in the
squid game for just participating you
know because you'd be like exotic
but you know how we do
we got to draw the correlation
because i'm half asian i think i can get
away with jokes like this yes but i know
that's problematic
let me proceed
jt you gotta honor your asian roots by
competing in the squid games buddy get
out there make [ __ ] happen kill whoever
you need to kill
cheat some people stab them in the back
doesn't matter what you're too nice of a
guy if you really are you're actually
like one of the nicest people i've ever
met you kind of exceed me a little bit
timid you would have the gihon
progression of a guy who's just way too
kind and you would ultimately end up
becoming an ultimate badass in the end
so jt
good luck
i'll see you on the field
i'll be one of the guys with the mass
watching
laughing
he's that japanese guy from hawaii huh i
love him hi jt i got money on you
[Music]